you might have heard the term LIBOR when
people are quoting interest rates or
they're saying hey I'm going to lend you
money a few percentage points above
LIBOR you'll hear LIBOR quoted on on
some of the financial news channels and
what it is is just an average of the
interest rates that banks are lending to
each other and it's calculated by the
British Bankers Association it's
actually calculated by Thomson Reuters
for the British Bankers Association but
it's there to kind of provide a
benchmark for other types of securities
and financial transactions and it
literally stands for the London
interbank offer rate so it's the in
London it's the it's the rate the offer
rate between banks it's the London
interbank offer rate and to understand
that a little bit better we I've set up
two banks over here at Bank a and Bank B
and you might already know that when you
go and deposit your money in banks the
bank won't leave all that money around
the way it makes money as it lends a
good bit of that money to to other
people as as loans and it will keep just
enough cash on hand that it thinks well
you know if people actually were to come
and ask for their money from their
checking account we have enough on hand
but you could imagine every now and then
a bank might get low on cash or it might
get close to kind of the reserve
requirements that the central bank in
that country requires a bank to have on
hand so in that those situations say
Bank a is getting to that that situation
it says let me go borrow some money let
me go borrow money from an int from
another bank so this is interbank
borrowing bank B over here they're flush
with cash and they say well we don't
like to keep so much cash around we want
to lend it so we can actually get
interest we get no interest on cash so
maybe Bank B lends money to bank a so
maybe they lend this much cash so that's
the new cash that Bank a got right over
there the new cash and of course it is a
loan so this is a new loan to offset it
remember assets are equal to liabilities
plus equity so now the liabilities is
this whole thing over here so this is
loan from from B for the
cash so that they have a little bit
better of a cushion and now be their
loans have increased and their cash has
decreased so this is a loan loan to a
right now they took this cash and they
gave it to Bank a and that rate that
they lent it at maybe it was at 1% maybe
it's a 1 percent annual rate and of
course this will be renewed every day so
it's an overnight rate this rate is an
interbank rate so what they do in its on
behalf of the British Bankers
Association as they go survey a bunch of
banks in London 8 12 16 banks in London
and say hey what was the rate at which
y'all transacted and then they will
quote that and they'll quote that as the
overnight LIBOR so they'll quote it at
say hey maybe it was 1.2 percent across
all of the banks that we surveyed and
what's interesting about the LIBOR is
it's done in ten currencies it's not
just in in the sterling or the dollar or
the yen it's in ten currencies and
that's what really differentiates it
well amongst other things but what
really differentiates it from the from
the effective federal funds rate which
is another interbank borrowing rate but
that's in the United States and that's
more revolving around policy concerns
because the federal the federal bank
actually tries to change it